[Music]
egypt
the richest source of archaeological
treasures
on the planet oh that's a fabulous one
beneath this desert landscape lie the
secrets of this ancient civilization
wow you see why the pharaohs chose this
place
now for a full season of excavations
our cameras have been given
unprecedented access
to follow teams on the front line of
archaeology
i'm driving so fast because i'm so
excited
it's an entrance we can see an entrance
revealing buried secrets have just been
told that they have found something
oh my gosh
a sphinx
[Music]
and making discoveries that could
rewrite
ancient history
this time new secrets of the boy king
tutankhamen alia uses pioneering
technology to reveal startling new
evidence
about his tomb and why it remained
hidden for three thousand years
a lot of robberies were going on how was
it not found
ace's team discovers a long-lost cache
of king tewton commons treasures
the most exciting discovery in my career
and alejandro discovers extraordinary
burial treasures
in a 4 000 year old tomb
[Music]
congratulations
[Music]
the valley of the kings
3500 years ago the great pharaohs
stopped building pyramids as their tombs
they chose these secluded cliffs to
become their cemetery
today archaeologists come from all over
the world
to unlock the mysteries still hidden in
this city of the dead
it's the first day in the valley for
cairo born egyptologist
aaliyah ishmael and her team
it's a real buzz in this place people
are coming from all over the world
coming to the valley it's amazing
i'm so proud to have such ancestry it's
one of the most famous necropolis
in the world and i think what is special
is that it comes out of nowhere
over 300 miles south of cairo in the
heart of egypt
lie the limestone cliffs of the valley
of the kings
after 200 years of excavation
archaeologists have located 65 tombs
hidden among the rocks
but only one has ever been found with
its treasure still
inside it belonged to the pharaoh tootin
common
this here is number 62
tutankhamun one of those great finds of
the century
british explorer howard carter
discovered tootin commons tomb in 1922
one of his teams spotted steps leading
down through the sand
they led to the tomb entrance buried
beneath
feet of rubble and debris
what carter found inside inspired
archaeologists for
generations to come
deep inside the mountains
amid a maze of tunnels that bored deep
through the rock
carter reached the tomb of tutankhamen
hidden right in the center of the valley
inside he found treasures unlike
anything ever seen before
over 5 000 priceless artifacts
including golden statues
in the burial chamber the pharaoh's
mummy wearing a golden death mask
was placed inside a coffin made of more
than
200 pounds of solid gold
this intact tomb made tootin common the
most
famous of the pharaohs now
aaliyah is investigating this golden
pharaoh's life
wow and why his tomb remained hidden
for so long elias team has been scanning
and documenting the tomb
for the last 10 years and they've made a
remarkable discovery
the idea here is to understand what's
going on when you look at the data
void of color the scans strip away the
paint on the walls
to reveal unusual markings this is the
main scene
and here is the 3d of the north wall
so as you can see here as a silhouette
of an image
and this would have been done while they
were painting
the images show the indented outline of
the face
hidden below it's caused by the tip of
the paintbrush
if you start painting when the plaster
is still wet
this is why the brushes would have made
a very light impression
and this allows us to understand that it
was rushed
but why would the tomb builders rush
such an important job
the pictures on the wall reveal another
set of clues
despite becoming the most famous pharaoh
of ancient egypt
tutankhamun did not have a lengthy reign
he was only a nine-year-old boy when he
became king
and relied on trusted advisors to help
rule
his vast empire as tootin common grew
older
he was known to portray himself as a
warrior king
riding into battle on a chariot
but the boy king suffered from multiple
illnesses
including malaria he was only 19 years
old
when he unexpectedly died
aaliyah thinks the marks her scans
reveal in the plaster
are evidence of a hurried burial due to
tootin common's sudden death
the decorated part of the tomb is very
small it's only the burial chamber
the rest of the tube is not decorated if
they had more
time all of this was going to be
decorated
while the tomb's construction may have
been rushed
its treasures were everything a pharaoh
could desire
to take him into the afterlife
so why did this tomb lay hidden below a
layer of rock for thousands of years
when all the other tombs in the valley
were looted
to solve this mystery aaliyah will turn
to new technology as she moves her
investigation
out into the valley
300 miles north in giza
in the shadow of the pyramids
the biggest treasure hall in history is
getting a new home
a one billion dollar museum and research
center
when completed the grand egyptian museum
will reunite all of tuten common's
treasures
in one place for the first time in 100
years
having all of the pieces from
together in one place this will be
a fantastic chance to find new facts
new hidden things about tutankhamun
after carter removed the treasures from
tut's tomb
they ended up in museums around egypt
now for the first time scientists and
egyptologists will use modern technology
to analyze each object some
details reappear and give us new
information
about these antiquities but
some of tut's greatest treasures are yet
to arrive
300 miles south in the luxor museum
asa zeedan is preparing 122 of these
priceless artifacts
for the move to giza
i'm very very proud to work with this
kind of the artifact
we have abuja responsibility for dealing
with the collection of tutankhamen this
is
once in the lifetime to move this
collection
to cairo asa's packing list
includes one of tut's famous chariots
intricate model boats and a unique head
of the cow
goddess hathor elaborately gilded with
gold
from my opinion as a head of cow like
the mosque of
ammon very important business in this
collection
[Music]
after just four hours asus packing
suddenly comes to a halt
one of his teams has discovered
something completely
unexpected in his store room it's an
antique box
that howard carter used to pack and
transport tootin commons
treasures out of the tomb i never
discovered something like that before
it's the most exciting discovery in my
career
the box has been missing presumed lost
for decades
and no one knows what treasures it may
hold
120 miles south of the valley of the
kings
near aswan a spanish research team from
high-end university
is hoping to follow in carter's
footsteps
and make new discoveries that could
rewrite history
professor alejandro jimenez serrano
heads the largest foreign team
working in egypt today is the first day
of the dig season sorry for the mess
we are sharing the room three
researchers of the team this is my
my bed supposedly the best one
sorry it's amazing to
get up and the first thing that you see
apart from the
ugly face of your roommates is the hawa
the hilo
cubet el hawa is one of the largest
ancient burial sites in egypt
so far 100 tombs have been discovered
here
they belong to the nobles who governed
egypt hundreds of years
before the pharaohs buried in the valley
of the kings
[Music]
alejandro's mission is to hunt for more
unopened tombs
and reveal more about these early
egyptians
it's difficult to explain how i feel
it's
not only nervous it's exciting it's a
mix of feelings
it's an honor to to come every year
now it comes the most difficult part of
the day
to climb the hill
this is the team's 10th year digging
here
so nice to be here again there's a
reason
why everyone is excited to be back last
year
alejandro found the entrance to a sealed
tune
but his permit expired before he could
explore inside
today is 40 degrees and working under
the sun
today is going to be tough
to protect against modern day tomb
robbers
they put a steel security door to block
the entrance of the vertical
shaft that leads to the sealed burial
chamber
well it has been one year waiting one
year imagine the possibilities
i'm very excited
in luxor ace's team packs tootin commons
treasures
for the move to the grand egyptian
museum in giza
[Music]
but in the storeroom asa is ready to
open carter's long-lost box
to discover what's inside
the team gathers around to see if the
box really does
contain priceless treasures from tootin
commons tomb
oh
fantastic it's amazing these delicate
wooden pieces
are ancient boat parts thank you mr
mohammed auto about this new discovery
storeroom records suggest they could be
missing
from a model boat howard carter found in
tutankhamun's tomb
this is the head of the one battle like
that
and the remains of the gold is still
there after all these years
according to ancient egyptian beliefs
boats played a key role after death
so placing model boats into tombs was a
vital part of any burial
the vessels also came complete with crew
because it was believed the replicas
would come to life
and help with fishing and transport in
the underworld
the pharaohs used a special vessel to
sail across the sky
for eternity ordinary people
also thought they could reach the
afterlife by boat
rowing on the nile and into the next
world
you can see here the date of the
newspaper is sunday
5th of november 1933.
howard carter maybe he reads this
newspaper before using
it as a support in this box to discover
where these pieces came from
mohammed inspects carter's original
inventory
here's the photo which taken for the
tomb itself and here we can find the
boat
it's number three two one and with the
master church which is here
records show that the box was sent to
luxor in 1973
but had gone missing presumed lost or
stolen
it's really exciting a new discovery for
one of the most important artifacts
belongs to the kingdom asa thinks the
rest of the boat is safe in the new
cairo lab
so they may finally be able to reunite
it
to transport the treasures to giza asa's
team
must traverse 400 miles of barren desert
roads
and crowded city streets before they
reach the safety of the new museum
it will take two trucks to transport all
122 of the artifacts to giza
this is a very very big moment for the
collection this is the final trip
but with such priceless relics on board
there's concern the convoy could be a
target
for a hijacking we have a good police
and good army they will follow us
during moving from luxol arrived to
cairo
with security in place it's time to roll
they now face a grueling 12-hour journey
through the desert
to reach giza before nightfall
ever since carter's discovery of
tutankhamun's priceless golden treasures
archaeologists have continued to try and
figure
out where and how the ancient egyptians
found
vast quantities of gold
50 miles south of the valley of the
kings
on the edge of the eastern desert
french gold expert thomas foshea and
archaeologist
john ward are on the hunt for the
origins of tewton commons gold
so i'm going to when you're waiting for
a traffic signal
the eastern desert covers 85 000
square miles of remote barren wilderness
some of the rock here contains tiny
grains of gold
locked inside thomas has studied ancient
gold mining techniques for seven years
now he wants to see if he can find any
evidence of it
but this part of the desert is a risky
place to be
the thing is we need to leave before
dark because it's not safe if we are
staying there because
we can lose our way we can have an
accident and it's also
at the sunset that all the snakes are
going out
snakes yeah very person no one told me
about
that on vapors yeah
the first stop an ancient well
it could provide clues to the location
of mining communities
during the time of tutankhamen
this is the world just in front of us
yeah
it's dry my god that's a long way there
the well might be dry today but it was
so important to the ancient egyptians
they built a temple to honor it it's
beautiful isn't it
i've actually applied a plaster [ __ ]
ceiling and then
applied the paint amazing
the text engraved on these walls reveals
clues about the gold miners
and where they were heading
ancient engineers built a network of
wells and rest stops
stretching all the way across the desert
each a day's walk
from the last
enabling travelers and miners to safely
cross
and explore the barren desert the temple
carvings
indicate these wells led toward the
mines
thomas hopes he will be able to find
some evidence of the people
behind tootin commons gold mining
operations
now it's time to go deeper east
like an ancient treasure map they must
follow the trail of wells
further into the desert
in aswan at the ancient burial site of
kubat al-hawa
alejandro is about to open a four
thousand year old tomb
they're on the hunt for whatever burial
treasure may be inside
i don't know who is more nervous you
know my team
after a year of waiting alejandro can
finally
enter the tomb it's amazing
it contains a 4 000 year old coffin
workers have inserted a box covered in
acid-free paper inside the coffin
to stop it from collapsing while they
examine the tomb
we have been very lucky it's impossible
to explain the feelings that
i'm having the burial consisted in
two coffins the outer coffins and the
printed coffin
among the debris of the outer coffin
alejandro spots something extraordinary
this is full of wooden models but
unfortunately
the outer coughing fall over them the
chamber is full of model boats
similar to the one in tewton commons
tomb to find
these funerary boats in a tomb is rare
today
but there's not just one there are four
complete with crew
you want to laugh you want to shout you
want to cry
this is the first time in 70 years a set
of boats like this
has been found this discovery gives
alejandro
an extremely rare opportunity to study
such important burial goods
but first he has to extract them from
the tomb
safely alejandro calls in his team of
conservation specialists
sarah and teresa i have one two
three four votes
very bad
yeah it's very difficult and the insects
eat their support
termites have attacked the wooden boats
sarah sprays on a liquid adhesive to
hold them together
so we will see if they are capable to
make a miracle
[Music]
they prepare a foam-lined cradle to
support the boat for the move to the
team's restoration lab
but the wooden hull is stuck to the tomb
floor
it'll require surgical precision using
scalpels
to free it from the tomb to the
restoration lab
we are talking about perhaps 40 meters
but
today is very windy which is very very
aggressive
the ancient boats are extremely fragile
get ready with a drop in the wind
the team sees the chance to remove the
first boat
yes
[Music]
well that was exciting
one of the best moments in my career
have one two three four five six seven
eight eight percent
it will take many weeks
to clean it and fix the pieces that were
broken some centuries ago
while the team gets to work on the boat
alejandro can
finally open the coffin to see who and
what is inside
in the middle of the desert the convoy
carrying tootin commons priceless
treasures
is two hours into its journey when asa
spots a problem i'm worried about
the shouting a thermal blanket
protecting tut's golden chariot is
coming loose
if it flies off it could cause a crash
we stop to make it safe
the unscheduled stop in the desert makes
this convoy
carrying the world's most priceless
treasures a potential target
for hijackers
asa and his team are unable to secure
the loose thermal covering
protecting tut's chariot some problem is
happening
removing the cover they risk the
scorching desert heat
potentially damaging the priceless
treasure
everything's okay now asa needs to get
the convoy moving
we hope to arrive to cairo safely
[Music]
in the valley egyptologist alia ishmael
is on a mission to discover how tootin
commons
tomb and treasures remained hidden for 3
000 years
a lot of robberies were going on in
ancient times and modern times
but it seems that this particular tube
was not found
how was it not found
the ancient engineers of tewton commons
tomb had a plan
inside the mountain they went to great
lengths to conceal the tomb
the pharaoh's burial chamber is located
26 feet underground
and is defended from the inside out
engineers constructed a wall to block
off the burial chamber
they filled the corridor leading to the
king with tons of rubble
before sealing a final doorway
and covering toot and common's tomb with
a vast amount of boulders under earth
standard tomb protection of the day
[Music]
but when carter discovered this tomb it
had more material on top
than any other in the valley
this may explain how it remained
undiscovered for
over 3 000 years but how did this extra
rock and debris get here
alia joins german geologist martin
ziegler to investigate
if you want to understand the evolution
of the body of the kings you need to
also understand evolution of the rock
martin thinks there could be clues in
the rocks at the entrance to a nearby
tomb
just at the entrance of it a slab is
just hanging above
a rock basically could fall out of the
cliff
egypt is hit with dozens of earthquakes
each year
so martin's installed a seismometer to
measure any vibrations that could
trigger
rockfalls with this one
we calculated to be away about 600 to
700 kilometers from the valley of the
kings
what if an earthquake would have were to
happen like much closer to the valley of
the kings how would it affect it
a very big earthquake could uh
destabilize some rock portions
so when you look in the in the history
of recorded earthquakes
the historic time scales let's say the
thousands of years
we have some records of earthquakes of
that type of magnitude
[Music]
so could rock falls caused by
earthquakes 3 000 years ago
account for the extra tons of rock that
covered the entrance to teuton commons
tomb
from the geological past and the
historic point of view we could have
rock falls or rock slides
that are triggered by earthquakes
covering tombs
but there are no cliffs directly above
tutankhamun's tomb
so it wouldn't have been hit by a direct
rockfall
how did so much extra material travel
down the valley
and completely cover the entrance to the
tomb
to solve this mystery alia and martin
must
take to the air
deep in the eastern desert thomas and
john are looking for
evidence of the miners who produce the
gold for tewton commons treasures
they're trying to find a route of
ancient wells
that the gold miners would have followed
as they traveled to the mines
it's like looking for a needle in a
haystack but i'm
losing a few kidneys
70 miles from the last ancient well
thomas and john
head into the unknown with their gps
broken down
they now risk getting completely lost
this piece of technology
is defunct it's not working
on the right side so we're now at the
back back end yeah so you need to turn
around
but after two days of searching john
thinks they may have finally found
something
what's that over there at the base of
that mountain there
so we found it
[Music]
okay so it looks that we found a very
interesting place here it's a settlement
it may look like scattered stones and
debris
but to thomas's expert eye he can see
the outline of ancient buildings
we have the huts where the people were
living and with the where they were
working
yeah we definitely have here this video
where i mean people have been working
here and we see
yeah there are even more over there as
they get closer
john spots the tools the ancient miners
would have used to extract gold from the
rocks
oh yeah that's running stone
that's a pounder yeah that's a pounder
yeah exactly that's what they would
break
yeah they would the quartz with yeah
it's the remains of an
ancient gold mining camp i mean how many
people were talking
20 30 yeah maybe we were like families
living here
[Music]
thomas has studied ancient mining
techniques for years
but seeing this evidence firsthand
brings home the hardship
the miners endured you start from a
piece of sports like this and you want
to make powder out of it so you need to
crush it
you have to imagine how much pain it
takes just to break a single
piece of quartz doing that like all day
long
in the sun pounding and ponding and
grinding and grinding and doing that for
years
evidence here paints a picture of the
life of desert miners
they cut shafts stretching up to 32 feet
deep
into the stone in search of precious
seams of quartz rock that contained gold
crushing the courts was a massive
undertaking
mining experts have calculated that a
team of 20 people would take a week to
process enough stone
to make just a spoonful of gold
that's heavy seriously sadly
there is very little evidence left of
these ancient mines
but these settlements provide new
insight into the communities that lived
such hard lives
processing the gold we have all the
material they were using
for sure that they were working here to
extract
and process the gold to send it to the
valley of the kings
we found it we found it
in aswan alejandro's team prepares to
remove the coffin
from the tomb they've opened
inscriptions reveal it belongs to a man
called shumai they have just struck the
lead of the coffin of chemin
rebecca you are the first person that is
looking at the shamai's face
in four thousand years
congratulations
[Laughter]
the inner coffin is intact but extremely
fragile
alejandro's team has reinforced it to
try and protect the mummy inside
it's just difficult to express the
feelings that i have now it's a special
moment
because i'm i'm studying this family
and it's almost my second family
[Music]
in the restoration lab the intricate
beauty of the model boats
is starting to appear termites have
eaten much of the wood
but their excrement has actually helped
hold parts of the boat together for
thousands of years we have some parts
that are still
in a very good state of conservation
this head of the
man it is covered with excrement of the
termites
but the wood is still visible
alejandro has spotted a figure distinct
from the other carvings
we can see in the middle of the boat
yellow face which belongs to a mummy
which would represent chemi
this exceptional discovery will help
archaeologists
understand the evolution of burial
practices in ancient egypt
[Music]
i was dreaming always to discover
something like this
um it's a dream that came
truth alejandro's next task
is to bring shamai's mummy above ground
for the first time
in 4 000 years
in the valley of the kings alia and
martin looked for clues to explain
why teuton commons tomb remained hidden
for so long
they've got special permission from the
government to use a drone to get a
unique perspective
on the position of tootin commons tomb
there we go
if you look down we should be over the
tutankhamun entrance right now
[Music]
now we can see the cliffs in the back
here we can see the central position
where we have the tomb
and above we can see debris
loose rock and debris cover the cliffs
behind
tut's tomb but the drone also reveals
these flood channels
carved into the rock by heavy rains over
thousands of years
and they could be the vital missing clue
we think that if we have flash flooding
that material can flow down
in this kind of channels
throughout history the valley has been
hit by earthquakes
and occasional flash floods
the flood waters push rubble downhill
toward the tombs
tootin commons tomb lies in a spot where
the channels of water
converge
and dump tons of rock
this combined with stone chippings from
a tomb built above
buried the entrance deeper
and kept it hidden for over three
thousand years
it's very exciting for me as an
ecologist to see to the commons tomb
from up here and see how it fits within
the valley
it is the prime location it is the one
that was most protected
he got the most sheltered tomb of all
tootin common was a boy king who played
a minor role in egypt's history
but because his tomb remained hidden for
thousands of years
his treasure was kept safe from robbers
and
made him the legend we know today
[Music]
in aswan the team is bringing the mummy
of ancient egyptian shamai
to the surface for the first time in 4
000 years
[Music]
this is the culmination of 10 years of
field work for alejandro
and an incredible opportunity to learn
more about shamai
125. it's quite short
my daughter is more or less like this
and she is eight years old
so i expected that
at least he he would be around 20 years
old or something
it has been a surprise i never expected
that
he could be just a boy
on his coffin it was written that he was
the person in charge of the
administration of the store
controlling the store you control the
people because you decide
who is going to receive food or not
this new evidence reveals shamai held a
powerful position
in ancient egyptian society at a very
young age
he may not have been a pharaoh but like
the boy king tutankhamun
his status afforded him a tomb and
burial goods
to ensure a safe passage into the
afterlife
it's taken 12 hours but finally asa and
his convoy of tutan commons treasures
arrive in the city
now we are in cairo welcome by crowded
traffic
very very very exciting we wait for this
moment
[Music]
turk tofic the museum director is
anxious to get everything
safely inside
[Music]
first cradles have to be taken out
in order for the two armor pieces to
start emerging
now i can say i'm very very happy
missions
it will be like unpacking christmas
presents
when we get out these pieces and find
out more details
about how they complement the whole
story
of king tutankhamun is
team can finally unpack the priceless
treasures
scientists and egyptologists can now
begin to study and analyze
each item in their new high-tech lab
top of the list are the newly discovered
boat pieces
[Music]
we check now in our database which of
them
may be related to any boats here in the
store room
for almost 100 years the boat that was
buried alongside
tootin common to help him travel into
the afterlife
has been missing its mast
[Music]
exactly
[Music]
it's very beautiful
[Music]
it's amazing that after all these years
we still have
new discoveries and new secrets for this
golden king
100 years after its discovery
tutankhamun's stunning treasure
is still surprising the world
[Music]
and the valley of the kings shows why it
remains the greatest place on earth
to hunt for the secrets of egypt's
famous
[Music]
pharaohs
[Music]
you